1 divided by 1 is 1.
1 divided by 0.1
means how many times is the decimal 0.1
contained within the number 1? The answer is 10 times.
We can move the decimal
point over 1 again and have 1 divided by
0.01, the answer to that is 100.
Our answer gets 10 times bigger every time
our denominator gets 10 times smaller.
1 divided by 0.001 is 1,000. So how small
can we go?  Well 1 divided by zero point
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
one, you can check on the calculator if
you like, but it's 1 billion. And we could
keep going smaller and smaller with our
answer getting bigger and bigger.
So will one over zero be as large as infinity?
It certainly looks that way. If
we draw a graph the smaller our number
on the bottom of the fraction, the bigger
the fraction seems to get.
Let's try it again but starting
somewhere else. 1 divided by negative 1
is negative 1.
1 divided by negative zero
point 1 is negative 10.
1 divided by
negative 0.01 is negative 100.
This time
when we move the decimal point over one we
are getting 10 times closer to zero and
our answer is getting 10 times smaller.
1 divided by negative 0.001 is
negative a thousand. And 1 divided by
negative zero point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero 1 is negative 1billion.
So now 1 divided by zero looks
like it might be minus infinity. As our
number on the bottom gets smaller our
fraction shoots down to huge negative
numbers. This shows us what the behavior
looks like as we approach one over zero
from both sides but at exactly zero the
graph is going in two different
directions. There is no answer to 1 over
0. 1 over 0 is not positive or negative
infinity, 1 over 0 is undefined.